Hello and good day everyone.
My name is Ronie Shilo and
I'm the director of professional programs,
here at the Stanford Center for
Professional Development.
It's my great pleasure to introduce
today's speaker for our webinar,
Professor Jeffrey Pfeffer from
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
He is the Thomas Dee D. Professor
of Organizational Behavior and
has taught in the Graduate School
of Business since 1979.
Jeffrey's the author or co-author of 14
books on the topic, including power and
organization, managing people,
evidence based management,
and the knowing-doing gap.
His latest book, Leadership BS: Fixing Workplaces and Careers, One Truth at a Time,
which we'll be hearing about
today was publish in September 2015.
Pfeffer is author of more than 150
articles and book chapters, and
has won numerous awards for
his scholarly research,
including an honorary doctorate from
Tilburg University in the Netherlands.
Pfeffer has taught seminars
in 39 countries, and
has been a visiting professor at Harvard
Business School, London Business School,
Singapore Management University and
IEFE in Barcelona.
Prior to joining Stanford, he was on
the faculty at the business schools
at the Universities California Berkeley
and the University of Illinois.
He has served at the board of directors of
several human capital software companies
as well as other public and
private companies and non-profit boards.
So definitely very accomplished,
and it should be a great
pleasure to hear him speak to us today
about his latest book Leadership BS.
So with that I'm going to
hand it over to Jeff.
>> Thank you very much, it's a pleasure to
be with everybody who's on the webinar.
The contact slide that Ronie just went
by had my contact information on it.
I would encourage people, if you have
questions not answered by the webinar, or
if you want to be in touch with me for
any other reason,
to email me at pfeffer@stanford.edu.
And so with that, we'll launch
into the content of the webinar,
which is about the book,
which is on the one hand controversial,
on the other hand,
some of it is complete common sense.
It is a book that is written based
upon the following observation.
And the observation is on the one
hand we have an enormous,
a huge, a gigantic industry of leadership.
For instance, there are more than 2.6
million entries on Google Scholar
such as just for the scholarly literature.
140 million results from a Google Search.
117,000 entries on Amazon.com
the estimates are McKinsey estimates
$14 billion spent annually on
training just in the United States.
I estimate using AFTB data
about 20 billion or above.
Robert Kennedy estimates $50 billion
a year, it's a big industry.
Virtually every business school and
many other places of
course have leadership activity
as a common part of their thing.
However, notwithstanding that we have just
spent all this money, and have done so
for lots of time,
workplaces by every single measure
that you can get provided by
virtually every source, are horrible.
There are low levels of employee
engagement, as reported by Gallup.
There are low levels of job satisfaction
and declining reported by Gallup,
by the Conference Board,
by Right Management and by Mercer.
You can look at the data yourself.
No wonder.
My favorite statistic in Parade magazine,
which used to be part of the Sunday
supplement in most Newspapers did a survey
in 2012 and found that 35% of US employees
said they would willingly forego
a substantial pay raise if their
direct supervisor would get fired.
So that tells you something about
the state of the workplace in spite of all
this leadership training.
And by the way, it is important to
recognize that the Gallup studies and
the other studies I have cited,
not this parade thing but
everything else, deals for
the most part with worldwide surveys.
So, this is not just a US problem.
This is a problem around the world,
lots of investment in leadership,
bad workplaces.
By the way, things aren't so
good for the leaders, either.
Leaders are losing their jobs.
CEO tenures are declining, have been for
a while, it's documented by
the Conference Board and consulting
firm lose, but it's worse than that.
A Stanford alumni group recently got
together in Washington DC to discuss my
book, and one of the leading polling
questions was, have you been fired?
And these are now Stanford people,
highly selective, highly motivated,
highly intelligent.
Certainly not a random
sample 60% of them said yes.
So it is not just an issue of you're
an Uber driver losing your job or
it's not just an issue there's
turn over at the top but there is.
These are people throughout the
organization who are losing their jobs in
spite of the fact that they have MBAs and
other forms of business education.
Next measure.
So we've got leaders using their job,
we've got workplaces are horrible
Face of all this big spin.
Third thing is go after companies.
How well are your leadership
development efforts going?
Are you getting good leaders?
Are you producing sufficient leaders?
And you have to understand that
the people that you're asking are biased.
To give you a positive answer because
they've actually spent the money.
Only 7% of senior managers polled by a UK
business school thought their firms
effectively developed global leaders.
An Accenture survey found that only 8%
of executives felt their company was
effective in developing leaders.
The answers for corporate productivity
reported that even among the best,
highest performing companies,
66 reported that they were ineffective at
developing leaders and were getting worse.
Bill Gentry at the Center for Creative
Leadership who has a new book out by
the way which I highly recommend, who
summarized numerous research studies noted
that one-half of all leaders and managers
are ineffective in their current role.
Leaders are failing,
as you know there's from 1999 to
2005 about 40% of companies and
their leaders got in trouble enough
to warrant major press attention.
Many Americans believe
there's a leadership crisis,
DDI and other global HR consulting firms,
that reported from a survey that one-third
did not consider their
own manager effective.
And their global leadership forecast,
noted that by their own admission leaders
are falling short, but leaders consistent
in the hallmarks of the quality of
the leadership in their own organization.
So my conclusion, based upon this is
that the leadership industry has failed,
as it continues to do what it is
doing it will continue to fail.
So then the question is what are the
causes and what might we do about it.
The first cause is that if you,
anybody listening to this call today can
go out and become a leadership expert,
there are no requirements you can't
go out today and do back surgery.
And you can't go out today and
build a bridge or fly an airplane, but
you can in fact be a leadership expert
of Ink magazines list of the top
leadership experts published in 2014.
Only four had a doctorate in a relevant
field one had no degree at all.
Two had degrees in divinity which I think
is actually important the leadership
teaching is a lot around lay preaching.
Five did not have any degrees in business.
As you go to the website which I did,
the expertise that the exports
are telling you is talking so
that they're great at talking whether or
not they're great at
doing anything certainly.
But I had a back surgery
a couple years ago,
when you get in a plane the number
one requirement for the pilot or
your surgeon is not
the ability I could describe.
Even I by the way could describe how to do
surgery, you wouldn't want me doing it.
So we do have a situation in which many
people are delivering material with no
qualifications.
And then they are able to do that because,
of course, the evaluation of most
of these leadership programs,
well some aren't evaluated at all.
Some that are evaluated or
evaluated by the expenditure of resources.
How many people want into the program?
How many hours?
Okay, that's fine,
some of them then are evaluated by what
do the people think of the program?
And these are sometimes
called smiley-faced sheets or
happy sheets where we ask people,
did you have a good experience?
Now the problem with a self rated
experience is that there is another field,
it's called education and teaching,
in which we know a couple of things.
The first thing we know is that student
ratings are correlated zero with
the objective amount of
material that students learned.
And secondly, we know that teacher
ratings are highly predicted
by 30 second silent videos rated
by other people of the teachers.
So you say, how can a 30 second silent
video of people who will never see this
person again, predict their teaching
ratings at the end of the course and
the answer is of course, that they
are both picking up on the same thing.
Which is some measure of personality,
social dominance, affability kind
of commanding the room, whatever.
None of which by the way, are necessarily
what we have been talking about which
is employee engagement,
success of leaders, etc.
So in the field of leadership development,
you reward, you get what you reward as
we've learned from the quality movement.
In the case of this you reward
entertainment, you get entertainment.
Few I know of none, companies assess
their interventions in their leadership
space by using measures that assess
the effects of leaders on their workplace
as such by employee engagement,
job satisfaction, turnover, etc.
Next, we're going to come back
to this divergent interests,
between the leaders and those led, and
even differences in measures of leader
well being and organizational success.
So when I was writing this book,
I gave a copy of the manuscript
to a friend of mine.
Very knowledgeable human being who's
been senior partner at Accenture, and
is now president of Menlo College
in Menlo Park California.
And has served on a number
of corporate boards.
He read the book,
he gave me some comments.
He said, by the way based on your book,
what should I do to be a better leader?
And I said,
that's an interesting question.
What do you mean by better leader?
I said, when Stan O'Neal drove
Merrill Lynch into the ground in
the 2007 financial crisis,
he left with $140 million.
Just your standard Mrs.
O'Neil, he did a pretty good job.
If you're one of the Merrill Lynch
people in the residue left behind,
he didn't do such a good job.
And there are many examples like that.
So I think what that example
illustrates is that we are way,
way, way, way too sloppy in thinking
about leader effectiveness.
So you tell me,
is this leader effective or not?
We have to specify the criteria.
Are we talking about work unit criteria?
Are we talking about
organizational level criteria?
Over what time period?
And even if we measure profit
margins versus profit growth,
depending upon how you measure
the margins of negative growth,
those things aren't
going to be correlated,
let alone be correlated with how
the leader has done for him or herself.
So you need to be I think very precise
about how we measure leader effectiveness.
And also recognize that what's good for
the organization is not good for
the leader.
You see companies layoff people all
the time if it helps their profits, but
it doesn't help the people laid off.
You see leaders leaving in
failed circumstances with huge
severance packages, even though
they destroyed the organization.
So there is a divergence of interest
that we need to pay attention to.
There's also an enormous
amount of conceptual
imprecision about leadership ideas, and
this is not just an academic issue.
So if I said we're going to improve
sanitary practices in medicine, which have
been a big problem, on which the Institute
of Medicines some years ago in a report
called Keeping Patients Safe, said we are
killing about 80 or 100,000 people a year.
In fact, we're going to improve
sanitary practices, we would say,
what are the sanitary practices,
how would we measure their occurrence?
So that we can actually then go and see.
How much of it are being done.
And if we had used interventions,
we could measure improvement.
If I say, we are going to have
more authentic leadership,
we've got a big problem.
Because as I've gone on the web there's no
definition, there's no precision about or
consensus about how to measure
authentic leadership or
decide whether or
not it's a good thing or a bad thing.
Nobody knows how to measure it.
If there's not consensus on measurement,
if we don't know what hand washing means,
in the case of medicine,
we cannot improve it.
And that's the case here.
So conceptual in precision, and we talk
about these things in very sloppy ways,
makes it hard to focus both
programs to make it better, and
assessments of whether or
not those programs have worked.
This is simple common sense.
So there are some remedies
obviously suggested
implicitly in what we've
talked about thus far.
One, we ought to measure outcomes.
I mean, any leadership program that only
gives out smiley face sheets I don't think
is doing the right thing,
because you got to measure outcome.
Over some time period,
I understand it's difficult,
but you need to measure satisfaction,
engagement, bullying,
turnover the number of potential
successors, leadership,
success in their jobs, do the people stay,
do the people being led like the leaders,
a bunch of things like that.
And, of course, we need to select
scientists not entertainers
to do the work of leadership evaluation
and I would argue leadership development.
We need to acknowledge
the conflicts of objectives and
then work to understand where they come
from and how they might be reduced.
Instead of just laughing
at the story of Stan O'Neil
leaving with a $140 million as
Merrill Lynch goes into the toilet.
Or Carly Fiorina leaving with $50
million and then going to run for
president on her business record,
her pretty spotty business record.
We need to understand
how this is possible.
Now banking, after the financial crisis,
there has been more attention to this and
they've got this idea of claw backs.
So if I make a lot of money
under false pretenses and
then the company falls apart I get to try
to get you to repay some of that money.
But this is not a talk on
incentive alignment, but
incentives I think are really critical.
And in many instances
the incentives are not aligned.
The senior executive incentives
are very often, way too short-term and
way too focused on things
that can be gained,
including obviously stock price,
which is gained all the time.
If you don't believe that,
just go back and
look at the history of
the thing with Enron.
I mean they gave people stock
options that paid off, so the stock
got to a high price, unfortunately for
a very,very short period of time.
So we need to do something to
align incentives way better.
Here's another problem
that I think we all face.
So the number one word,
probably not the number one word,
it's one of the common words.
The number one word that is used about
me and my books and my Fortune blogs,
I do blogs on Fortune.com,
I have a column about twice a month.
Is that it's dark, or
that it's depressing, or
that it's I don't know what.
So the opposite of dark or
depressing, of course, is inspire!
And the leadership world
loves inspiration.
So I gave a talk at
the Vlerick Business School.
I was going to use an example from
that talk in my book, and so I said,
I better make sure I
spell Vlerick correctly.
So I went to the Vlerick Business School,
which is a very good business
school in Belgium's, website.
And the first thing on their website is,
looking for
an inspiring management course.
Australian Graduate School of Management's
website notes that the school creates
inspirational learning opportunities.
I've spent some time on some websites
of engineering schools, law schools,
medical schools.
They will talk about material
that is professionally relevant,
that is scientifically rigorous,
that is well delivered,
that it is available online into
various learning modalities.
But I don't see many people going
to medical school to be inspired.
[LAUGH] Or to law school to be inspired.
They're going to medical school and
law school to be educated
in professionally relevant
knowledge that they are then going to
be able to use in a substantive way.
And so I think our search for inspiration
is not only kind of a joke, but
it is extremely harmful, and by the way
this goes on inside of companies as well.
First of all, it turns leadership and
leadership writing and speaking and
whatever into a form of lay preaching
because now we're into inspiring people.
If you were to read
Sigmund Freud's Delusion and Dream and
compare his discussion of the origins and
functions of religion to those of
the leadership industry, the parallels
are, of course, quite striking.
And the real problem with inspiration,
I want to be inspired.
And so if I wanted to be inspired
in medicine, I would take,
well, most people die of
pancreatic cancer in a year, and
the five-year survival
rate is close to zero.
But somebody, I'm sure there is somebody
who would have survived by, and
this distribution,
there's always somebody at the tail.
So let's find this wonderful inspiring
person, put them in front of an audience,
and give an inspirational talk
about surviving pancreatic cancer,
which by the way will do nothing to
improve the finding of a cure for cancer,
the treatment of cancer for anybody in
the audience, but it's kind of inspiring.
So the search for inspiration drives
the use of rare and unusual examples.
And you see this all the time.
So one of my good friends who's
endorsed this book, Jim Collins,
wrote a book called Good to Great.
You read Good to Great.
He started off with 1400 companies,
as I recall, somewhere between 10 and 15,
maybe 11 or 14 made the transition.
So if you were a betting man,
you would not make that bet.
I mean, rare and
unusual examples are interesting, but
they don't really inform a lot
about what we should do.
And secondly, the search for inspiration
leads to the reconstruction and
misremembering of events to produce
an uplifting inspiring narrative.
The book which was made into a movie, Lone
Survivor, of the poor guy who survived
out of the 16 Marines dumped
into Afghanistan turned
out to be quite inspiring, also turned
out that the more they looked at it and
talked to other people,
turned out to not be completely true.
Inspiration, that's another problem.
It is a horrible way to accomplish change.
It sets unrealistic expectations for
ourselves and
others, it raises motivation,
but only for a short time.
Many of the inspirational stories you
hear, I would say all of them, so
when you hear some inspirational
story about some fabulous CEO,
do about 30 minutes of due diligence, and
my bet would be you'll find a good
portion of what you heard is incorrect.
And by the way, we know how to
accomplish behavioral change.
If you have a drug problem,
a smoking problem,
an eating problem,
a problem with alcohol, all of these
interventions to change your behavior
with respect to food, drink or
illegal drugs, or for that matter, legal
drugs, all understand several principles.
Number one, your behavior is a function of
the social environment in which you are.
So you're much more likely to drink
if you're surrounded by drinkers,
much more likely to smoke if
you're surrounded by smokers,
much more likely to gamble if you're
surrounded by gamblers, you get the point.
And therefore, one of the first things
these intervention programs do is,
I'm going to separate you from the people
engaging in the behavior that we
want you to stop.
So we need to worry about that.
Secondly, we understand
the importance of measurement.
In the words of the quality movement,
that which gets measured gets done.
So that goes back to the measurement
thing we talked about.
We also know the importance
of visual priming.
It's how casinos and retail stores work.
It is why Brian Wansink, the famous
guy who has a book about dieting,
says that the best way to lose weight is
serve your portions on smaller plates,
because large plates cue you to eat more.
[COUGH] So instead of worrying
about inspiring people,
if we worried about measuring priming,
giving people reminders of what they
should do and not do, we would be in much,
much, much better shape.
So, the recommendations that follow from
this is to do due diligence on leaders, so
that you know that the stories are true.
Stop chasing inspiration,
you need facts, not fables.
And understand the pitfalls of
trying to learn from rare events and
extreme examples.
They can be instructive, but
you will see that the great 14 people,
14 companies make the transition.
To me the interesting question is,
what about the common sense things that
Collins recommends is so difficult to do.
And how could you make them easier?
Okay, next we're going to talk about
trade-offs, ends versus means.
Everybody wants to do great things,
but they want to do it in nice ways.
New York Times, June 15th, 2014.
Where Dishonesty is Best Policy,
US Soccer Falls Short.
Turns out you want to win soccer games,
you gotta be able to fake injuries.
I just watched the match between
Rio Real Madrid and Atletico.
And you can see them,
somebody touches somebody, aah,
they fall on the floor or whatever.
Anyway, the article asks the question, are
Americans bad at playacting, and if so,
should they try to get better.
Gamesmanship and embellishment
are part of high-level soccer.
Players exaggerate contact.
They turn niggling knocks into
something closer to grim death.
You can add, by the way,
take that and substitute a few words.
Are Americans bad at playacting?
If so, should they try to get better?
Gamesmanship and embellishment are part
of not only of high-level soccer,
they're part of organizational life.
People exaggerate
the amount of work they do.
They turn middling projects into
things that are huge accomplishments.
So an interesting issue.
Many of the most celebrated
leaders engage in behaviors and
use strategies that I'm willing to bet
are completely outside of almost what
virtually every leadership
development program features.
So everybody who says, I want to be
a great leader like Abraham Lincoln, but
nobody's going to teach you
to be like Abraham Lincoln.
You go watch Lincoln,
the fabulous movie, what did Lincoln do?
Lincoln lied about his intention to
free the slaves at the start of his
political career.
Lincoln lied about where the Southern
delegation was when he was trying to
end the war.
Lincoln, in order to pass the 13th
Amendment that outlawed slavery,
was willing to basically go down to
the floor, well, send his emissaries
into Congress and trade positions,
basically sell positions for votes.
Now this is like in any leadership
program you want to read about.
Nelson Mandela, completely inconsistent,
one day a raging communist and
a proposer of violence, and sometime later
a peace person interested in capitalism.
You can go down the list.
All of these people were willing,
because they were so
committed to accomplishing something,
they were willing to do whatever it took.
So if I have to tell you a little story.
If I have to not tell you
what I'm really going to do.
If I have to, say one thing one day and
a different thing the other, I'm willing
to do that in order to accomplish this
major change that I'm trying to get done.
This is a wonderful thing which I
would urge you to read on your own.
It's Why Machiavelli Still Matters,
from an article,
an opinion piece in the New York Times,
December 9th, 2013.
I would highlight only one sentence,
which is Machiavelli teaches that
in a world where so many are not good,
you must learn to be able to not be good.
And then the proper aim of a leader
is to maintain his state and
not incidentally, his job.
There are never easy choices, and
prudence consists of knowing how to
recognize the qualities of
the hard decisions you face and
choosing the less bad as
what is the most good.
So this, the Kumbaya nature,
of the leadership industry and
the Kumbaya which I just find now not only
offensive, but completely unhelpful for
what we are trying to accomplish
in making leaders effective.
I just find it distressing and
not helpful.
Because, like here, we have students
from Stanford, believe it or
not, go out into the world,
I believe in openness and transparency.
Not a problem.
What happened?
Well, I'm on the phone with you
because I'm about to get fired.
Why?
I told my boss what I thought of her.
[LAUGH] Not a good thing to do.
[LAUGH] Unless your
opinion is pretty high.
So I mean, we're sending people out and
they are losing their jobs or
they are having career setbacks.
And I find that just really halucious,
but whatever.
Perhaps the biggest problem of
all in this leadership role,
is the confusion between
what should be and what is.
In the leadership domain we have a big
discrepancy with how we believe leaders
ought to be, leaders ought to be
honest and open and transparent and
tell the truth and look out for
the well being of others.
And, by the way, there's a lot of research
that suggests if leaders did that,
the workplaces would be better,
that employees would be happier,
their engagement levels would be higher.
People wouldn't be saying
on the parade survey that
I'd give up a substantial raise
to get rid of my boss, etc., etc.
And then we need to look at how leaders
actually are, understand that discrepancy,
and understand why it exists.
And I'm going to give you just a couple of
examples, but these can be fixed as well.
And the two questions to ask about the
oft-touted leadership attributes is there
any evidence that most or many leaders
display the desired behaviors and
since they don't,
what is the logic for the opposite?
And by the way,
you can play this game out as you look
at the current political campaign.
Since the leading candidate for
the most part bear almost no resemblance
to what we claim a leader should be or do.
One example is modesty.
Here we go, that is in fact the chapter
in a book written more than two and
a half years ago the name
Donald Trump appears.
So Jim Collins does a great highlight
of Level 5 leaders who were
characterized as being both driven but
also incredibly modest.
So you didn't see their names all
over the news, media, and whatever.
Modesty is, of course, a virtue.
And most importantly,
modest leaders share credit with others.
And in sharing a credit with other people
is more likely to attract other people,
because people are more likely to work on
a project for which they get some credit.
Secondly, people are more
likely to work on a project for
which other people listen to them.
And thirdly, when people give you credit,
you feel better about yourself.
So modesty is a good thing to do.
But in a book called The Productive
Narcissist written by Michael Maccoby,
he noted that many of the most venerated
business leaders exhibited high levels of
narcissism.
Steve Jobs, Jack Welch, Larry Ellison,
Donald Trump in a book that was written 20
years ago, so the person doesn't change,
Michael Eisner, and a bunch of others.
And we know, from research on narcissism,
that many, many, many studies, and
you can look this up on scholar.google.com
which accesses the scholarly literature.
And look at the effects of, if you put in
a phrase, the effects of narcissism, and
you'll show, so what you'll find is
that many studies show that immodesty,
self-promotion, self-aggrandizement,
and unwarranted self-confidence
reliably helps people obtain leadership
positions in the first place.
Then once in them, affects their
ability to hold on to those positions,
get higher pay, and even helps in some
dimensions, though not all of group and
organizational performance.
And so if we want modest leaders
we need to understand, number one,
why are we selecting for the opposite?
And number two,
what about immodesty is helping people and
how are there other ways to accomplish
that or build organizations where
these qualities don't have the same
positive effects that they currently do?
Second example would be authenticity.
There's a big authentic
leadership movement
represented by Bill George's book,
True North, written with my colleague and
former MBA student, Pete Sims.
The idea is that people ought to be
true to their real inner thoughts and
feelings, to their inner character,
that you need to be true to yourself.
And that if you're not true to
yourself and put on a shell or
put on an act, people can see
through attempts at deception.
And, by the way, people prefer to
relate to people who are authentic.
Great leaders are great actors.
And, by the way,
if you believe you can see through people
who are putting on a show, good luck.
There's been a bunch of
empirical literature on this.
People are very bad at uncovering lies,
even when they're told to do so
and they're told that some of
the people talking to them are lying.
And all you need to do is look at
the Bernie Madoff financial scandal or
many of these other things.
We believe what we want to believe and
we're quite bad at uncovering deception.
Authenticity itself may be impossible
because it says be true to your true self
but what true self is that?
Is it true to your managerial self?
Yourself as a parent, yourself as a child?
Yourself in various relationships?
We occupy in our lives numerous roles.
And in each one of these roles we have
to do and be slightly different things.
And authenticity is about being
true to your inner self but
leaders need to be true not to themselves,
but to what the people in their work
setting want and need from them.
So when Gary Loveman,
who at the time was running Harrah's,
which then became Caesars the big
casino company, came to my class.
And for the first time in 2004,
after I had written a case on him,
he arrived, he did a great job.
It was only at lunch that I learned
that Gary Loveman had the flu and
was running a temperature
of 101 degrees Fahrenheit.
Now, as a sentient human being,
the last thing Gary Loveman wants to do,
if he's being true to himself,
is show up in my class sick as a dog and
spend two sessions talking to these
students who he doesn't know.
But he understands that part of his
deal is he's agreed to do this,
I'd have let him off the hook.
But part of the deal is
he has the capacity to,
I feel like hell, doesn't matter.
I'm with employees who will see me
once a year, I have to look energized,
engaged, concerned.
Even if my daughter's giving me trouble,
even if there are marital issues,
even if I'm tired beyond comprehension,
leaders need to be authentic and
true to what the people around
them want and need from them.
My second example would
be Allison Davis-Blake.
I like to say I knew Allison Davis-Blake
before she was hyphenated.
When Alison Davis was a doctoral student
at the Stanford Business School,
she was smart, nice,
decent, the most painfully
shy human being I have ever
encountered in the world.
If she spoke in class which she almost
never did, you couldn't hear her.
Allison Davis-Blake is stepping down this
year as the Dean of the Ross School of
the University of Michigan, one of
the leading business schools in the world.
She told me a couple weeks ago
that she is a finalist one of two,
for a provost position in one of the top
50 universities in the United States.
You do not get from where
she was to where she is
by being the shyest person in the room,
some person that no one can hear.
The idea that Alison Davis-Blake should
have been true to the original Alison,
who couldn't talk, who had no or exhibited
no self-confidence, is just I think nuts.
People remake themselves all the time.
And if you're going to want to
be successful you have to.
Now, let me give you some final
recommendations, and then we'll have lots
of time for questions, because on my
computer it says it only 10:38, and
I was supposed to go to
approximately 10:40.
How do you like that?
Just on time.
My bosses here are always pleased.
Not that I should a good job, but
you should do a good job on time.
That's even more important.
So, if you want to improve I think
if we're serious about making,
leadership better than
it's been in the past,
I think the first thing we need
to do is both understand and
then maybe remedy the disconnects between
what leaders say and what they do.
Lots of leaders talk about doing all
kinds of things many of them don't do it.
You know I'm nice, I'm whatever,
they self advertise the wonderful calling
that they display and then you go then
you hear pretty much the opposite.
We need to worry about and do something
about the disconnect between prescriptions
from leaders and the realty of
actual leaders behaviors and traits.
I think one of the big problems in
leadership today is that we tell people to
do things that, while they are
aspirational and great In many respects
are so, discrepant with what we know
about fundamental human psychology and
leader behavior that we're basically,
it's like going to church.
We're telling you to be this this
person that nobody is going to be.
And so it's kind of an interesting
disconnect that we need to remedy.
We need certainly a remedy to disconnect
this from leader performance and
what happens to those leaders, the fact
that many of them have no consequences for
their bad behavior,
which goes on all the time.
We also need to remedy the disconnect
between what most people think to want
which is uplifting stories about
relatively rare events and
what I think most people need.
You know one of the reasons why medicine.
I believe has made much more
progress than management.
Is that medicine is much
more science based.
So when you show me lots of people
dying on pancreatic cancer.
I'm not going to find the one that doesn't
make this person into some role model.
I'm not going to say, wow!
The death rate for
pancreatic cancer I find depressing.
It's unacceptable, but not depressing.
It is what it is.
If what it is,
you are going to make it better,
you are going to understand why it is and
how to make it better.
You are going to evaluate your
intervention in terms of whether or
not they generate improvement.
This idea that you ought to be in
the inspiration business is crazy.
And then I'd finally impress most
importantly, we need to evaluate
leadership development programs by
their actual effects on human beings.
On what they do, on how they do it,
on their own leadership on,
you know, on employee engagement,
we need to have a much more, an evaluation
system that evaluates something,
whether or not we had a nice time or
liked the [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the end of my
follow up presentation,
it is on time by my schedule, and so
we will now let you ask questions or make
comments or do anything else you want.
I very much appreciate
the wonderful high attendance, and
I hope you will all take this message
extremely seriously, and not say,
well this is depressing, a word that
I don't really believe we should use.
>> All right, so thank you Jeffrey for
the really wonderful presentation and for
being on time
>> And
I will take a few minutes now to ask.
There have been many,
many questions that have been coming in.
So we'll do our best to
answer some of them.
And so Jeffrey,
one of the questions that came in.
Related to this theme of gamesmanship and
being authentic not to yourself but
to the people around you.
What are some ways that you
found that you can understand
what the others around you
are wanting you to be?
>> Well I think you need to develop
the skill of empathic understanding.
And that is,
number one you need to listen.
And number two you need to understand
what they're what their perspective is,
from how they're being paid,
how they're being evaluated,
what their educational background is.
So a combination of what are their
key performance indicators?
What are they trying to get done?
And they may not be trying to get
done what you're trying to get done.
So to take the simple example of my
poor Gary Loveman coming to my class,
Gary Loveman understands, intuitively
because he understands the situation.
That students in the class
expect to see him.
They expect to see him and they expect to
be able to engage with him with energy and
intensity.
And just because he's running
a 101 degree fever and
doesn't feel well,
their expectations have not changed.
So I think in almost
every situation we can
figure out how people are getting paid or
rewarded?
What are their professional backgrounds?
What do they say about what
they want out of a situation?
And then try to as a leader
understand that as you put together
how you want to present yourself.
One question that came up that I found
interesting was around the theme of
when we speak about training, we often
think about athletes that train and
we often,
there's some programs that use coaches or
athletic coaches that come
to speak about leadership.
Athletes have a very strong
drive to become better
athletes how about leaders
going to these programs?
What are your thoughts on their own
motivation to become better leaders?
>> That's a fabulously fantastic
question because in many instances I
think the individual leaders who are sent
>> to these programs
are often see them as kind
of a checker box activity.
My company is sending me, I want to go.
It's better then working.
They may send you to a nice resort, you
get good food, you're here with somebody
who doesn't challenge you too much and
it's pretty entertaining.
I think the difference between an athlete.
By the way there's another difference.
The athlete's come to specifically,
develop a very, very, very,
very specific and measurable skill.
Whether it's throwing a football or
jumping or swimming, or, running.
Running a certain distance.
Running at a certain speed.
And evaluation of the coaching is done.
So I got a coach,
at the end of the day I'm no better
doing whatever I want for the coach,
for the coach has failed no matter how
entertaining and inspiring they had been.
So the nice analogy with the athlete for
me, is not only whether or
not the athlete is self motivated, but
also whether or not the coaching or
the training is very behaviorally focused.
And in athletes it is, and
in leadership it often is not.
>> Thank you.
That's really interesting, and
kind of ties to your sense of
medicine as a scientific approach,
where leadership is not.
Do you have any examples of places
where this measurement of leadership
achievement or
success has been successful?
Where an organization has been
successful at doing that?
>> Sure, there are not many but
there are a few.
I think DaVita, which is a kidney dialysis
company now called DaVita Healthcare
could be expanded into the primary
health are is a place where their
operating culture is no brag, just facts.
And so
they are an extremely fact based place.
I can recall their CEO telling me a story
about somebody he hired to be in charge of
their Red Woods program, which is
the leadership development program.
And they have people who are nurses and
who have worked up through
the ranks of the nurse manager.
And they have people who come in as MBAs.
And he noticed that the people in
the program were mostly the MBAs,
and he said to the guy
running the program.
You need to have equal
opportunity in this program for
the nurses because we want a balanced
set of leaders between the nurses, and
the people with business school degrees.
And about six month later he went back and
sat down with the guy and
he said have you fixed the problem?
The guy looked at him and he said no.
And Camp looked at him and
he said do you understand what
that means and the guy says yes.
He says I have to leave.
Literally, one was the stories is people
don’t do it, they fire themselves.
So yes, I say there are companies,
I mean DaVita measures that the values,
DaVita measures of employee engagement.
So you have to make, to make these
measures you have to take them seriously
And they would be one example.
>> Great.
There's a question here about women, and
how they can differentiate and
become better leaders.
So, some of the traits that
you mentioned are perhaps
not very compatible with the way women
behave, or may perceive themselves.
Do you have any thoughts on that?
Sure, which will be quite controversial.
Or not.
I mean if you read Sheryl Sandberg's
book Lean In, I mean her basic advice is
do the best you can and not carry all
this psychological baggage with you.
When I, Allison Davis-Blake.
Can give you instance
after instance in which,
because she is a woman, and looks,
by the way, younger than her age.
She's had all kinds of
assumptions made about her, and
all kinds of other stuff has gone on.
And Alison's response to that
has been to say, basically,
women have to be twice as good to get
half the rewards that fortunately we are.
Get over it the world is not a just and
fair place don't carry
the baggage with you.
And in fact is one of the things that made
her successful, the ability to you know.
She's often proactively gets justice for
herself.
I can tell you a story about
that if you're interested.
But in many instances this is just as bad.
Yes this happened, you know I'm
not going to take this personally.
I'm not going to let it
emotionally effect me.
I'm basically, going to let it roll off.
And just continue to do what I think I
need to do and be what I need to be.
And not get, I'm so, men or
women, I don't care who you are.
If you had asked him what are the critical
characteristic to be successful in life
let alone in the forms of life that we're
talking about, persistence and resilience.
I mean you know the Venus Williams,
Serena Williams they'll win
all the tennis matches.
Life is tough, the higher you go
the more competitive it's going to be.
You have to be willing to you know,
you have to be willing to in boxing terms,
to be able to take a punch.
You have to be able to knock down and
get back up, and
one of the people that if you look, and
think about it who have been the most
persistent and resilient I think succeed.
So William Brown,
the most powerful African American
Politician in the United States,
Mayor of San Francisco twice, Speaker of
the California Assembly for 14 years.
Lost his first race for the Assembly.
Lost his first race for the Speakership.
You have to be able to
survive the setbacks and
the stuff that people throw at you.
>> So, I mean in that you also
answered some questions that came in.
We're just asking what are some of
the key leadership traits in your mind?
And perhaps those would be persistence and
resilience.
Is there anything else you'd
like to add to that list?
>> I would say resilience and
persistence for sure, and
the ability to read other people.
Not necessarily for their benefit, but
the ability to know where
other people are coming from.
That would be another.
A fourth which people underestimate
is the effect of energy.
Emotions are contagious.
Energy is contagious.
Everybody In this room, everybody's
listening to this podcast understands.
I would say that when you around a boss or
colleague, you're fast and
got lots of energy and excitement.
It rubs off on you and when you're
around people who are down, it rubs off.
So energy is the ability
to work could not sleep.
I mean, the ability to have a lot
of intensity to what you do
brings I think something.
And the fifth thing that I would talk
about is the ability, in the book
I talk about it, in the Power book I talk
about is the ability to tolerate conflict.
But it's more than that.
It's the ability to not be right.
So I have a friend who I talk about
a lot in the power book whose
just been named by TIME magazine as 100
most influential people in the world.
Woman who is changing medicine and
treats breast cancer very successfully.
And I was in a meeting with her once,
and she's tough.
She's a little nicer now than she used
to be, but tough and not very patient.
And somebody said you know, Laura,
I don't like your personality.
And you know she said when 45,000 women
a year are not dying of breast cancer
we can talk about my personality.
And until then shut I'm going to
choose some excellent him up.
[LAUGH] The point being, if you're trying
to achieve important changes and do
things that nobody else has done before,
you will almost invariably upset somebody.
Because the status quo remains the status
quo because people don't have interest.
And it remained in the status quo, and
so you're going to have to change it,
people are going to get upset,
you can't let them worry you.
>> Thank you, so
one other question is around leaders who
are focused on their personal success
versus their organizational success,
it's perhaps tied into
the incentive question.
How can organizations,
perhaps channel that, personal
success drive of leaders to their benefit.
>> Well, the topic of incentive
alignment would take us a whole other
hour to talk about.
But let me suggest that when
you see individuals acting in
their own selfish self interest and
against the interests of the organization.
Besides blaming the individual and hoping
somehow, you're going to get rid of that
person and bring in somebody else
who's going to be different.
You really need to understand that,
that this is a system's problem.
That the organization is producing that
behavior, you want the behavior to change,
you need to change the environment
in which that person is working.
You need to change the cultural messages.
You probably need to
change the incentives.
You probably need to change.
What's cueing that individual.
Maybe you need to change the person
that the individual is reporting to.
Because oftentimes we say this
person is acting like blah,
how is that individual's boss acting?
Often the same way.
We're modeling the behavior, so
we can't just say good or bad person.
We need to do something
about that individual.
We need to look at the forces,
the messages that are getting sent
that are reinforcing that behavior.
>> So perhaps in closing,
one last question.
This whole hour,
we've been talking about leaders.
Is there any advice that
you'd give to followers?
>> Become leaders.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I mean that we live in a hierarchical
world, the evidence is clear in a book
written by the British epidemiologist
Michael Marmot,
health follows the state is gradient.
The more education, the more wealth,
the higher position,
the longer your likely to live.
So yes, I think people in a in a
hierarchical world in which there's income
inequality, there's health inequality,
there's access to everything
that's reasonably unequal.
You need to decide where you
want to be in that distribution,
but if you want to be at the top
then you should go for it.
Leaders by the way are not born,
they are made.
Everything that we have
talked about today and
a bunch of stuff we haven't talked about
today are skills that can be learned.
And I think Alison, one of the reasons why
I'm so thrilled by Alison and her career.
And where she's gone and
how successful she's been is, she provides
I think a case illustration of the point
that if Alison was painfully shy.
The word painfully shy was probably
written, the phrase, about her.
If she can go from there that two
being able to give talks in front of
hundreds of people and.
You know, the senior corporate executives.
We haul out the big
deal provost search and
get offered university presidencies and
other deanships all the time.
This is something, this is personal,
this is a journey,
a personal transformation and growth.
But it is a journey and everybody's
journey obviously is going to be distinct
But everyone can make their own journey
to become what they want to become.
I want to thank Jeffery Pfeffer again for
this really insightful presentation and
I wish all of you a very good day.
>> Thank you.